[Müzik]
Herkese merhaba biraz heyecanlandım
galiba Sesimi duyunca Öyle hissettim
birden
arkadaşımız Call Center'daki mutluluk
süreçlerinden bahsetti ben de buna
benzer şeylerden bahsedeceğim Bugün size
Hatta bundan Tam 10 sene önce
devlet opera binasına bir modern dans
gösterisine gittim ve gösteriye
girdiğimde gülme krizine girdim böyle
nasıl gülüyorum ama salondan cik cik
sesleri geliyor
Ay çok gitti ya salondan cik cik sesleri
geliyor
inanılmaz gerildim ama hikaye şöyle
başlıyor
Ben o gün gösteriye geç kalıyorum son
1-2 dakika kalmış içeri giriyorum bütün
kapılar kapatılmış bir görevli arıyorum
içeride bir oraya O kapıya koşuyorum bir
diğer kapıya koşuyorum Derken dedim ki
Şu kapıdan gireyim en iyisi içeri girdim
kendime
birden dedim ki ya yanlış kapıdan
girseydim o sahnede hayal ettim dansçı
Kadınlar böyle beyaz perdelerin
arkasından pıt pıt sahneye düşmeye
başladı hayal ediyorum Diyorum ki ben
diyor sahneye bu şekilde düşseydim ne
yapardım ama nasıl gülüyorum böyle
arkadaşımın yanına oturdum diyor ki Niye
gülüyorsun rezil ettin bizi ne bu hali
Durduramıyorum Kendimi bir türlü
dedim boş ver Hani sakinleştim ve
gösteriyi izlemeye devam ettim Peki
neden Hayal kurarız
Biz Umut olsun diye mi yoksa mutlu
olduğumuz bir ağız hasarlamak için mi az
önce anlattığım andaki gibi işte saçma
bir şeydi kurabiliriz bu ben
çocukluğumdan beri Hayal kurmayı çok
severim ve bu benim her zaman
motivasyonum olmuştu ondan kopuk
yaşıyorum işte bulunduğum anda mutlu
olamıyorum anlamına gelmiyor
Hayal kurdukça mutlu oluyorum
başarıyorum başaramadığım şeyler yerine
de farklı motivasyonlar buluyorum
araştırmacılarda diyor ki Beynimiz boş
kaldığı zamanlarda Aslında geleceği
programlamak üzerine tasarlanmıştır yani
Çocukluğumda şeyi denerdim siz de
yaptınız mı bilmiyorum Beynimdeki tüm
sesleri susturmayı nasıl olacak ya bunu
meditasyon yapan insanlar
belli bir seviyeye geldiklerinde buna
ulaşabiliyorlarmış ben hiç öyle bir
seviyeye ulaşamadım ve zaten böyle bir
şey de yokmuş Hani o insanları teyze
ederek söylüyorum
genellikle
çok pardon hastayım bir de bir taraftan
Genellikle bu süreçte
motivasyonlar konuşmalarda şey yapıyoruz
işte
Daha öncesinde diyorum ki ben bu anı
yaşadım yıllar önce bir arkadaşımla
hayal kuruyoruz dedim ki ben tedbir
olmak istiyorum TED konuşmacısı olmak
istiyorum Buna Uzmanlar ön deneyim diyor
daha öncesinde o anı hayalinizde
yaşadığınızda süreciniz Sizin için çok
daha kolay ilerleyebiliyor benim için
sadece konu mutluluk değildi ama
mutluluk da hayatımın amaçlarından
biriydi
uzun yıllardır beyaz yakalı olarak
çalışıyorum uzun dediğimde 5 sene
Aslında Elf olsam Belki hayatımın bir
senesine denk gelirdi
bu süreç benim için son zamanlarda
birazcık zor gitmeye başladı ve
mutluluğumu baltalıyor gibi hissediyorum
ama şimdi sizden şey istiyorum yani Tüm
bu hayatımızdaki olumsuzlukları
bırakalım ve hep birlikte yüzümüze
kocaman bir gülümseme koyalım tüm
salondan bunu istiyorum herkese şu an
kontrol ediyorum
arkalarda yapmayanlar var görüyorum
Lütfen herkes gülümsesin Hatta
gözlerimizi kapatalım böyle bir nasıl
hissediyoruz Kalbimiz nasıl atıyor
heyecanlı mıyız mutlu muyuz yoksa farklı
duyguları içinde miyiz Ömer Sen de biraz
gülebilirsin
parkta duyguları düşünmemiz ben
Bunu neden yaptırıyorum size Aslında
ünlü psikolog doktor
sarahman'ın dediği bir şeyi test etmeye
çalışıyoruz Kendisi diyor ki sadece
mutlu hissettiğimiz zaman gülmeyiz
güldüğümüz zaman beynimize gönderdiğimiz
sinyallerle kendimizi mutlu
hissedebiliriz
Ben de konuşmamın devamında tüm salonda
Mutlu olduğuna emin olmak istedim bunu
Günlük hayatınızda da deneyebilirsiniz
bu triyi hani
kötü hissettiğinizde yüzünüze bir
gülümseme koyun ve hayatınıza devam edin
Şimdi size bir hikayemi anlatacağım
tekrardan
geçen sene bu zamanlar Ankara'dayım
O tuzuma da geliyorum kalmış 5 ay dedim
botoks mu yaptırsam acaba sağdan soldan
duyduğum işte Geç kalırsan çizgiler daha
da derinleşin ne kadar erken o kadar iyi
bak Ben yaptırdım yüzümü nasıldı parlak
cümlelerinden de etkilenmiş olacağım ki
ben botoks yaptırayım en iyisi ablam var
Ankara'da yaşıyor Aradım onu dedim ki
ben botoks yaptırmak istiyorum hemen
randevu aldı gittik botoksu yaptırdım
Şimdi Sağdaki fotoğrafa lütfen bakın ben
istediğim sonucu alamadım Böyle o
gülüşüm o samimiyetim yok olmuş gibi
geldi yüzümdeki o kırışıklıklar gidince
ben sanki anılarımı kaybettim ve
hatıralarım silinmiş gibi oldu Diyorum
ki bu bu değildi benim istediğim
kesinlikle
ve botoksun beni Mutlu etmediğine karar
verdim
şimdi
[Müzik]
bunu geçiyorum
mutluluğunda pardon çok özür diliyorum
buradaki amacım Sağdaki fotoğraftaki
gülümseme mi Nasıl kaybettiğim Aslında
Bakın
size nasıl geliyor bilmiyorum ama ben
bunu yaptırdıktan sonra Yüzümde bir
sahte gülümsemeyle 3 ay boyunca dolaştım
sanki 3 ay boyunca o gülümsemeyi
kaybetmiştim ve üniversitedeyken bir
hocam da dedi ki
Eğer Yüzünüzdeki izleri silerseniz
hatıralarınızda silersiniz beden kayıt
tutar tam olarak benim Yüzümdeki izlerle
beraber tüm hatıralarımda gitmiş gibi
oldum
mutlulukla Aslında gülümsemeyi birazcık
bağdaştıracağım mutluluğun
insanlık tarihinde iki türünden
bahsediliyor genellikle hedonik mutluluk
ve ödeme mutluluk
mutlu olmamak için aslında çoğu zaman
engelleri önümüzde kendimiz koyuyoruz ve
bu süreç genellikle şöyle ilerliyor
bu ayakkabıları aldığım zaman mutlu
olacağım Hayır hayır yeni bir iş
bulduğum zaman daha çok para
kazanmalıyım daha çok para kazanmak beni
daha mutlu edecek Hayır yeni bir şehre
taşınayım evleneyim tatile gideyim o
zaman daha mutlu olacağım derken emekli
oluyoruz ve bir bakmışız ölüyoruz
Aslında bu engellerle beraber
istediğimiz noktaya ulaşamıyoruz
mutluluk yolunuzu Eğer bu şekilde devam
ettiriyorsanız Tabii ki bunu hedefler
çok güzel önümüze koymalıyız ama bunu
hayatımızın amacı haline getirdiğimizde
biz normal mutluluk seviyemize hızla
dönüyoruz ayakkabıyı aldım okey O gün
benim için çok güzel geçiyor ama iki gün
sonra bu standart bir seviyeye geri
dönmüş oluyor o yüzden
araştırmacılar Bir de ekstra olarak
ödemelik Mutluluktan da bahsediyorlar
onunla hayatımızı nasıl devam ettirmemiz
gerektiğini Şimdi size bununla alakalı
bir Araştırmadan bahsedeyim Öncelikle
çok özür diliyorum hemen bir adımsa
alalım
araştırmamızda Kahraman 2004 yılında
kahraman ve Arkadaşları
909 kadın çalışanı
909 kadın çalışanı diyorlar ki gününüzü
nasıl geçiriyorsunuz gününüzü geçirirken
nasıl hissettiğini sıfırla 6 arasında
oynayın
araştırmanın sonunda çeşitli aktiviteler
aktivitelerdeki ortalama mutluluk
seviyemiz
tabloda gözüktüğü gibi en çok seks
yaparken mutlu olduğunu söylüyor
kadınlarımız Ama bu araştırma batıda
yapıldığı için ülkemizin kadınları
tarafından ne kadar geçerli bilemiyorum
sonrasında sosyalleşme rahatlama yemek
yeme ve egzersiz bunu takip ediyor
ikinci olarak da en çok kimin yanında
mutluyuz Peki bir de buna bakalım
araştırmacılarımız diyor ki; en çok
arkadaşlarımızın yanında mutluyuz
sonrasında realitif yani aile anne baba
Kardeş bunun içine girebilir eş ve
çocuklar geliyor Ben kendim için bir
sıralama yapacak olursam Öncelikle ben
de ilk sırayı arkadaşlarıma koyarım
ikinci sıraya eşimi koyarım ama eşim de
benim eski En yakın arkadaşım olduğu
için
onu birinci sıraya da koyabilirim Çünkü
salondan çıkıp gitmesini istemiyorum
3 sıraya ailemi koyuyorum annemi
kardeşlerimi ve 4 sırada henüz çocuk
olmadığı için
Köpeğim viskoyu koymayı tercih ediyorum
belki Çocuğum olunca bu sıralama değişir
Diğerlerine baktığımda yani işte
müşterilerle kovworkerlarla ne kadar
mutluyuz çok da emin değilim
Şimdi gelelim diğer mutluluk çeşitimiz
ödemelik mutluluğa ödemedik mutluluğu 6
temel unsura dayandırarak anlatmış
Bunlardan ilki
çevreni kontrol edebilme yeteneğin Yani
bu ne demek oluyor hayatınızın
kontrolüne Çevrenizde ne olursa olsun
kendi elinizde tutun ikincisi Kendini
kabul etme doğrununla yanlışınla İyi
yanlarına kötü yanlarına Kendini kabul
edebilme üçüncüsü kişisel gelişim
kişisel gelişimden kastım burada
hayatınıza devamlı olarak bir şeyler
katıp bir Yeni deneyimler peşinde yeni
bilgiler peşinde koşup kendinizi
geliştirmeniz 4 sırada otonomi yani
bağımsızlık geliyor
Elalem ne der diye düşünmeyin ve kendi
çizdiğiniz yolda korkmadan yürümeye
devam edin
beşinci olarak diyor ki hayatınızda
kendinize bir amaç belirleyin bunu
belirlemek Bazen çok zor olabiliyor işte
kendi hayattaki amacınızı bulmak En
azından benim için öyle oldu ama o amacı
ya da amaçlarınızı bulduğunuz ama ona
tutunum ve onun üzerinden gidin son
olarak da pozitif ilişkiler kurun
Çevrenizdeki insanlarla pozitif
ilişkiler kurmaya Özen gösterin
dünya mutluluk raporu 2021 dünyaya
mutluluk raporuna göre
raporu Ben burada tersten koymayı tercih
ettim 149 ülke arasında en mutlu yüz
ikinci ülkeyiz ama rapora iyi tarafından
bakacak olursak bizden mutsuz 44 ülke
daha var arkadaşlar
Afganistan 1 sırada geliyor
son zamanlarda Böylece Coğrafya kaderdir
lafını çok fazla duyar oldum bu da işte
Coğrafya kader mi Değil mi birazcık
üzerinde düşünmemize neden olabilir
Peki en mutlu ülkeler hangileri hiç
şaşırmadığım şekilde
Kuzey Avrupa ülkeleri
Finlandiya'da 4 senedir birinciliği
çekiyor yani Finlandiya'da ne oluyorsa
artık oradan bir danışman mı gelir
ülkemizde mutluluk ekibi
sıradan daha üstlere nasıl çıkarız ve
düşünmemiz gerekiyor
peki
para mutluluk getirir mi
diye soruyorum
araştırmacılar diyor ki
deneyimsel
yaşadığınız ya da paranızı
bağışladığınız zaman ya da zamanı satın
aldığınız zaman
daha mutlu olabilirsiniz karşılaştırma
yapmışlar Demişler ki işte materyalist
şeylerle denimsel şeyleri
karşılaştıralım paranızı Hanginiz
harcınızda daha mutlu oluyorsunuz ve
deneyimsel şeyleri işte tatile gitmeye
arkadaşlığına yemek yemek gibi
aktivitelerde daha mutlu olduğumuz
görülmüş yani
arkadaşınız bir çift ayakkabı almakla
arkadaşınızla bir gecelik tatile gitmeye
günü birlikte tatile gitmek arasında
kararsız kalırsanız günde Birlik tatili
seçebilirsiniz Çünkü bu sizi daha mutlu
edecek Ben buradaki örnekte günü
birlikte tatili vermemin nedeni aslında
burada
şeydi bu yemekle karşılaştırılıyordu
ayakkabı fiyatlarına Bakınca dedim ki
Ben bununla yemekten fazla şeyler
yapabilirim günübirlik tatile de
gidebilirim O yüzden bu şekilde koydum
örneğimi
sonrasında Cömert olun Cömert
olduğunuzda
bunu hayal ettiğinizde bile mutluluk
seviyenizin gözle görülür bir şekilde
arttı kanıtlanmış paranızın ne kadarına
Cömert olarak işte arkadaşlarınızla
harcadınız ailenizle harcadığınız
miktarı önemli değil önemli olan
harcayabilmeniz ya da bağışlayabilmeniz
bu da sizi daha mutlu bir insan
yapacaktır
gelelim birazcık da benim alanım nöro
Marketing satın alma davranışları
üzerine uzmanlığım var Birazcık da satın
alma davranışlarına bakalım mizahın
gülmenin mutluluğun bu davranışları
üzerindeki etkileri nelerdir
müşteriler mutluluk için normalin
üzerinde ödeme yapmaya hazırmış yapılan
bir Global araştırmada
insanlara sormuşlar insanları yüzde 45'i
Ben 2 yıldan fazla süredir mutlu
hissetmiyorum
yüzde 25'i demiş ki ben mutluluğun ne
anlama geldiğini unuttum Nasıl bir şeydi
bu
Tablo bu kadar karamsarken insanların
yüzde seksen sekizinin de gülmelerini
sağlayacak yeni deneyimle aramızda garip
karşılanamaz Bence Ve bu çok büyük bir
oran insanlar gülmek istiyor gerçekten
ve
insanların yüzde 91'de markaların komik
olmasını bekliyorlar ama ben böyle
üzerine düşündüm de çok da fazla komik
marka hatırlayamıyorum hani böyle
tepsiyle Coca Cola'nın şeyleri vardır
karşılıklı atışmaları vardır İşte
McDonald's'ta Burger king'im vardır Ama
özellikle Türkiye'deki markalarda bu
mide unsuru çok da kullanılmıyor ve
Aslında yöneticiler Pazarlama
iletişimlerinde
bu mizah unsurunu kullanmaktan
çekiniyorlar linç kültürü sebebiyle ben
kendi markamda bunu deneyeceğim ve
gerçekten sonuçlarını merak ediyorum
insanlar Gül kendilerini güldürdükleri
markalara daha Sağdık ve daha fazla para
ödemeye hazırlar çünkü
Peki güldüğümüz zaman beynimizde neler
oluyor biraz da ona bakalım güldüğümüz
zaman beynimizde
nörokimyasallarda endorfin salgılanıyor
bu ağrılarımızı azaltıyor serotonin
salgılanıyor bu bizim daha
modum şeyimizin Duygu durumumuzun
stabile olmasına sağlıyor ve güvende
hissediyoruz dopamin salgılanıyor
dopaminle beraber daha enerjik oluyoruz
motivasyonumuz yerine geliyor Bir de
ödül sistemiyle alakalı bir hormon
kendisi
Ayrıca güldüğümüz zaman duyusal ödül
sistemlerinde işler
oluyor Yani bu ne demek güldüğümüzde
güldüğümüz zamanlarda karşımızdaki
kişilere son olarak bunu da ekleyeyim
güldüğümüzde karşımızdaki kişilere daha
samimi daha içten Daha çekici geliyoruz
ve bu karşımızdaki kişiyi ödüllendirme
bize yetiyor birlikte gülebildiğiniz
insanlara teşekkürler
[Alkış]
[Müzik]